there is a there is an argument that the
kind of capitalism
that was created and developed and
evolved in the last say a hundred years
has led to the kind of extreme wealth or
greater wealth up now most more people
in the United States for example or
Western Europe it is that you think that
that is part of why we experience
greater freedoms or is there something
else that interacts with with our system
that allows not only more money to be
flowing than say it was in in the early
1900's but also allows more rights to be
flowing across just you know discrete
groups I'm not sure if there's a real
connection between the amount of money
available and the liberties one over a
period of time there probably is but I
can't think of it right now I think what
really happened over say the years
between 1900 and today is that the
people who were oppressed black people
working people women people in the
middle gay and lesbian communities all
these disparate people found their voice
and found the ability to struggle and
found the ability to say I'm not taking
this anymore I'm going to fight as hard
as I can I'm going to join in with
others of a common cause to address
these issues and I'm going to reach out
into the larger community and find
people there who are my potential allies
and make them my allies but to do all
these things and these will change my
condition and eventually will change the
condition of all of us I think that's
really what's happened for say from 1900
until today I don't think the amount of
money available has had that much do
with it although somebody could make the
argument and convince me but I think
it's the ability of the people
themselves to do it not not the money
building on that night so there's more
money involved you know I'm thinking I
remember some years ago I had gone to a
wealthy man to get some money for the
n-double-a-cp I was chairman of the
board and ask him for a hundred thousand
dollars and he said no that's not enough
I was astounded because I was asking for
a hundred-thousand-dollar
this man gave me 20 million dollars with
the provision I spend it between july
and november of two thousand so in those
few months i had to spend all this money
and think of this you have to spend this
money you have to spend in a legal way
you have to spend in an effective way
you have to show some result of it I was
lucky enough to find a remarkable woman
named Heather booth who could spend this
money for me spend it honestly fairly
judiciously spend it in a proper way and
knew how to spend it and knew who could
help her spend it and she did it but the
thought that I would have somebody give
me twenty thousand twenty million
dollars never crossed my mind until it
came into my lap and I've been looking
for this guy ever since